- This is a one-man operation.
I do the whole thing myself.
The Saguache Crescent is
the last hot-metal newspaper
in the United States.
And probably about anywhere.
(languid music)
My family purchased the newspaper in 1917.
It's just what we've always done.
You know, it’s either stay in it or get out,
and it's easier to stay
in than get out actually.
I've been working here
since I was 12 years old.
I've been publisher for 37 years.
The linotype that I use to set the text
for the newspaper we
bought brand new in 1921.
I have about 440 subscribers.
I print about 530 papers.
We've put in anything that
people want to announce.
You know, anything that's going on.
A lot of times it's an obituary.
(hammer taps)
All right.
(languid music)
I've just maintained the
traditional printing method
at The Crescent simply because
there hasn't been any reason to change.
I'm not old enough for it to
have completely worn me out.
I've just been able to
just go on week to week.
The future of the paper is
that it'll be put out
next week I'm pretty sure.
Probably a week after that, and,
it could be 20 years, it could be two years.
I don't know.
I think I'm as amazed
about it as most people.